[Music]
you're impressive they're gonna be
obsessed with you
they're not as nihilistic as they look
on the internet you guys this is me oh
whoa this is your first relationship oh
no you just kind of give that vibe
well you know that has weed in it right
[Applause]
who wants to play bodies body spotties
so how do you play
you draw the piece of paper that has the
X on it you are the murderer let's go
and if you're the murderer you have to
kill someone by touching them on the
back
the most important part if you come
across a body you have to yell
[Music]
is that the lights
David
foreign
is dead
as soon as there was trying to kill us
off one by one that'll be so obvious if
I were the killer chicken off my clothes
in the window for The Neighbors
[Applause]
what are you talking about
I'm staying safe really because it looks
like we're grabbing meet Cleaver to go
look for my boyfriend
who's watching a girl
[Music]
I brought something what is it it's
zucchini bread
yum oh God
[Music]
oh
[Music]